in this video you're going to learn how
to simplify square roots involving a
negative number so we're going to go
through six examples together and you're
going to learn how to do this the first
thing we want to talk about is what
exactly is the square root of negative
one well the square root of negative 1
we represent that with this letter i for
Imaginary think about it for a minute
see if you had the square root of a
negative 16. see when you take the
square root it's really saying what
number times itself is equal to this
quantity underneath the square root so
when you look at this one you say well
if I take 4 times itself that's positive
16 or if I take negative 4 times itself
that's also positive 16. so how can I
take the square root of a negative
number and that's where the I comes in
so let's take a look at the first
example and I'll show you how this works
so when we have the square root of
negative 48 we can break this down into
the square root of negative 1 times the
square root of positive 48. the square
root of negative 1 we represent that
with the letter i I for Imaginary and
then the square root of 48 we can break
this down into 16 times 3. now the
reason I picked 16 is because it's a
perfect square you try to pull out the
perfect squares like 4 9 16 25
Etc and then it's easy to take the
square root of 16 that's just going to
be 4 so we end up with 4 I
square root of 3. now the square root of
3 is kind of like the remainder it's
like the leftover this is not a perfect
square so that stays underneath the
square root sign
now let's look at number two I'm going
to show you a different way of
approaching these so the square root of
negative 72 again we can say this is
like square root of negative 1 times
square root of positive 72 the square
root of negative 1 we represent that
with the letter i for Imaginary but this
time instead of dividing out perfect
squares let's do a prime factorization
tree let's see what 72 is made up of so
9 times 8 is 72
3 times 3 is 9.
4 times 2 is 8 and 4 is 2 times 2. so
you want to break it down until you get
to just the prime numbers which are the
numbers that can only be divided by one
in themselves then what you do when
you're taking the square root is you
look for two of the same number like a
pair of the same number it doesn't have
to be the number two it just has to be
the same number twice and so what we do
is we group those together and for each
group we pull one out in front of the
square root sign the reason being this
is like 3 squared see 3 times 3 is 3
squared what's the square root of 3
squared that's just going to be 3 or
another way to think about it this is 9
what's the square root of 9 just 3 this
is 4 what's the square root of 4 that's
just going to be 2
or you can think this as 2 squared and
the square root of 2 squared the square
and the square root cancel one another
out just leaving us with 2.
and then we have this I here in front as
well and then we have this 2 here left
over that's going to stay underneath the
square root it's kind of like the
remainder so if we multiply these
together now we get 6i square root of 2
and that's your final simplified form so
a lot of people like this prime
factorization tree a little bit better
especially when there's larger numbers
if you know perfect squares that divide
out just quickly you can do that it
might be a little bit faster but again A
lot of people do like this method for
number three now let's look at this one
square root of negative 150. well we
know this is square root of negative 1
times square root of positive 150
square root of negative 1 we know is I
for Imaginary 150 let's break that down
into 15 times 10 15 is 3 times 5 and 10
is 5 times 2 and look there's that pair
that we were talking about that's like 5
squared and the square root of I squared
is just 5 or you can think of this as 25
the square root of 25 is just 5. so that
5 comes out in front of the square root
we have the I there as well and then
what we have left over is this 3 and 2
which we're going to multiply together
that's six that stays underneath the
square root and you've got it in fully
simplified form let's take a look at
three more examples okay if you feel
like you're getting the hang of these
see if you can pause the video and try
these last three examples on your own
and we'll go through them together
so for number four what would you do on
this one the square root of negative 81
well again you can break this down into
square root of negative 1 times the
square root of 81
square root of negative 1 we know that's
I for Imaginary square root of 81 what
number times itself is 81 that's just
nine but we put the number in front in
the I second so this would be written as
9i
okay for number five try this one the
square root of negative 128 how would
you do that one
now that's a larger number so this one I
might use the prime factorization Tree
on so this is really like square root of
negative 1 times square root of positive
128 square root of negative 1 we know is
I for Imaginary 128 is 2 times 64.
64 is 2 times 32 32 is 2 times 16. 16 is
2 times 8 2 times 4 2 times 2
and we're looking for groups of two of
the same number so let's see what we
have here we have one group of twos
two group of twos three group of twos
with one two left over so this is going
to be 2 times 2 times 2 which is eight
I
with a square root of 2 left over now
remember for each group you end up
getting one of these so this is two
times another 2 times another two okay
and that's how I'm getting eight you
don't want to say 2 plus 2 plus 2 and
say six or
you know some other combination you want
to take for each group one of those out
and again remember this is like 4 square
root of 4 is 2. this is like 4 square
root of 4 is 2. let's try the last
example number six now what would you do
on this one square root of negative 54
well let's see this one let's try it uh
by pulling out perfect squares on this
one so we could do square root of
negative one
54 is actually nine times six square
root of negative 1 is I for Imaginary
square root of 9 is 3 and we have this
square root of 6 left over but we
generally write the number here first
the I second and then our radical here
our square root is six and that's the
final result so great job if you want
more examples you want to see another
video I did talking about simplifying
square roots I'll put a video right
there that you can check out I'll see
over in that video